hello everybody my name is markiplier
yamimash that's it that's the one here
we go hi yeah Barsky no why you kill me
why not that's the celebratory start of
any of our Let's Plays yeah it's dark in
here we're playing horror dream are a
dream we just carry we just played a
really good one with yamimash oh I was
brilliant and I have a feeling mine's
not gonna be anywhere nearly as good by
the way in the videos we did on my
channel there was a lot of advertising
for a certain project yeah that we're
not gonna mention here yeah definitely
no not mention this product and oh yeah
ever then people are all like what what
what was it oh no are we gonna tempering
the down oh did you see what I did when
you made that sound on the Stargate
episode on my channel I know what you do
oh yeah all you need to watch is like
the first two minutes it's baby well I
know is when we made our pinky promise
you swore at me haha
I swear with you what are you talking
about that's the American version of the
pinky promise no no don't be oh my god
don't talk to me okay all right fine
geez going FF you you stupid with a Nina
well look where we go
I said garage what did i do what did I
do I don't know I'm you live ahead no
yes he talked to you hello mark no I
would I would not be absolutely not if
you were my other head I could not deal
with that I keep you awake all night yes
you would Oh
someone draw a fan ordered of us as
Siamese twins just at the head hey we
can either just at the head I mean it
the body like two-headed thing not now
there's gonna be fan of us joined at the
head and that's not what I wanted that
isn't and then they'll be mark you match
Siamese twin us you uh you press the
switches I did they didn't do nothin Oh
trust me that they did nothing they
can't meet the door and we're all
there's some binder there we go all of
this vents
yes is a van oh no get out the van uh
hold on I just need to move this other
way cuz it was a moment I hear lovely
strange noises
it sounds very very sexual mmm um this
sounds sexual to you I don't even want
to know you don't know what I do in my
spare time
oh that actually is quite um beyond ik
sure is I'm Bionic
I'll be Attic that's which is my doing
it wrong commit you're doing it wrong do
this to my feet let me use my boy boy
boy
crash oh you'll bomb it's like the
biggest mess in your body yes
yeah the strongest muscle in your body
is your tongue a little a little oh geez
whoa hey whoa family show only thing
they want us to go through but the same
time they kind of like just twisting our
nipples if you get you'd go I mean yes I
hate it when they want me to do
something and then they just twist my
nipples it's just nothing no nose man no
whoa huh hello you go that way oh
there's nothing over her he wants you to
come over I'm um hello I'm concerned he
sounds nice he sounds friendly does he
he does not actually do you not
understand her though he's gonna just on
alien language do you I speak fluent flu
peas but I can't stand those flu pians I
like to speak some flu pians me that was
a reference to a joke I made in that
video yamimash did which I don't even
know what you can only find over on the
Army masters channel okay here we go
you should definitely click that thing
on my face or whatever and go to my
channel
Marty mmmm nothing you murderer I know
how could you I hate boxes I could I
could give you a about your box
what so what did the boxes teach you and
you as a kid oh it was horrible
well I I said oh you must tell me your
story I can't do it
it's not from the beginning mark oh
there we go this is partially open door
is now unlocked you be anyone the
outside has the Curtis the boxes it's
okay mark you call me I'm going
the boxes they pulled up in a van okay
honey they gave me candy and then they
gave me a teddy bear and then with me 20
bucks me they gave me go watch and then
they send me home and then I never saw
them again
uh-huh whose game boxes I'll never
forgive them you still have you go to
watch No thank you guys sold it for
money
wait what do we go oh CatDog whoa whoa
whoa awesome
it was a dream oh hey don't hand me uh
oh my god why Park in the beginning
please slip away from me yeah sorry I
was just yeah how's a little bit inside
you there you slippy slippy thing you
yes I know I'm sorry
okay so hey that was the game I guess
Wow huh what was that that was things
well the thing is that killed in the
last one the paintings
yeah oh the thing in the mirror was that
was that it yeah if you want to know
what we're talking about click on the
ominous is beautiful face over there
well not that face oh I just thought
that face is no no no don't do that
oh don't worry that why you could be
like that you gotta ruin everything are
you sorry yeah yeah I'm sorry
sounds like you need some coal and blow
to fix your problems right up just talk
to my desk yesterday and way where I
didn't kill you it doesn't work you're
calling blowing a sham
by travelpod member
Oh
it looks like you're about to give me
something oh I'm about to give you
something all right
oh just rude get ready dude right all
right
I'm very ready yeah uh yeah so intense
all right so good I know right all right
number one ah another one no what do you
like are you crazy no one can take two :
blows well I'm still here
can you handle it are you still feeling
that that uncomfortable bloating
sensation I think I've got a bad date to
the Colin blood here take some of this
three of these a day will help solve
your aching problem mmm don't you enjoy
I know oh yes I feel so cleaning free
thank you dr. mark a plan welcome home
blow has changed my life it and it can
change yours too if you call now you can
order 32 bottles of colon blow for 29
easy payments of $39.99 swalot yeah life
life life is so dark
life is just filled with sadness life is
just no meaning
Who am I what does it even mean to be
human many of us even really know uh can
any of us we even really say I don't
know anymore